So Lauren just mentioned phobia when she talked about agoraphobia. So, the
question then is well, what is a phobia? Well a phobia is a persistent and
unreasonable fear of a particular activity, object, or a situation. So, for
instance let's take social phobia. Social phobia then is an unreasonable and
persistent fear of social situations. Fear of being scrutinized and humiliated
by other people. Now, this fear can be limited to specific social situations,
like public speaking, or it can be generalized to most any social situation.
The problem with social anxiety and social phobia though, is that it can be
self-perpetuating. Meaning that by being anxious in social situations you might
draw more attention to yourself from other people and that in turn just builds
on the anxiety.